Point free. Should we? I mean, I didn't delete it. We'll actually take before we get to the profiling. Let's take this. We're going to take a small interlude here. Welcome to ADSP, the podcast episode, recorded on April 19th, 2022. My name is Connor, and today with my co-host Bryce, we continue Part 2 of our four-part interview with Ben Dean on C++ algorithms.
无参数。我们应该吗？我的意思是，我没有删除它。在进入性能分析之前，我们实际上会先拿这个。我们在这里做一个小插曲。欢迎收听 ADSP，本期播客录制于 2022 年 4 月 19 日。我是康纳（Connor），今天与我的联合主持人布莱斯（Bryce）一起，继续我们对本·迪恩（Ben Dean）关于 C++ 算法的四部分访谈的第二部分。
One of the things, too, that in going over both the blog that I still have not gone back to find that individual's name, but if you're listening, your name will come up in either this episode or part two of this episode. What blog is this? Actually, we can just go find it right now. Because that's great podcasting, serving the internet live. Here we go. Felipe, I wrote the solutions you guys discussed in this episode.
还有一件事，在回顾那个博客时——我还是没去找那个人的名字，但如果你在听，你的名字会在本集或本集的第二部分中出现。这是什么博客？实际上，我们现在就可以去找它。因为这是很棒的播客表现形式，在互联网上进行直播。我们开始吧。费利佩（Felipe），我写了你们在这集里讨论的解决方案。
I'd appreciate it if you could have a look at the reduce slash transform, reduce. And let me know if this is what you had in mind. Love the episode. So thank you, Felipe. I responded. And yeah, it looked good. I only perused it quickly. He was missing one of the function objects or lambdas called max two underscore accumulating. But other than that, it looked good. This podcast is now so big that people write commentary on the podcast. It's not that big uh i was talking to jason the other day at the denver c++ meetup and ours is uh not an order of magnitude smaller but we got a long way to go uh to call it big as being generous swag i need swag for c++ now do we have stickers do we have a logo no we put and here's the thing uh we one time got a request for uh transcripts um but we have to understand is we will get transcripts as soon
如果你能看一看 reduce / transform_reduce，我将不胜感激。并告诉我这是否是你想的那样。非常喜欢这集。所以谢谢你，费利佩。我回复了。是的，它看起来不错。我只是粗略地浏览了一下。他漏掉了一个名为 max_two_accumulating 的函数对象或 lambda。但除此之外，它看起来不错。这个播客现在太火了，以至于人们都会为播客写评论了。它没有那么火，呃，我前几天在丹佛 C++ 聚会上跟杰森（Jason）聊过，我们的规模——也不是小一个数量级，但我们要说它很大，还有很长的路要走，呃，说它大未免太慷慨了。随性说笑，我得现在为 C++ 搞点周边！我们有贴纸吗？我们有标志吗？不，我们……还有一件事，呃，我们有一次收到了获取文字稿的请求；但我们要明白的是，只要有公司愿意出资，
as some company offers uh to pay but it's not cheap to because like i do not have the bandwidth to uh go and you know have them automatically generated and then clean it up um and so the alternative is and i know bryce doesn't have the bandwidth either and then clean it up. And so the alternative is, and I know Bryce doesn't have the bandwidth either, and neither does Ben, and neither would he be interested in doing that. But so you have to- I did that once. I think it was the Conspect for All the Things talk
我们就会有文字稿，但这并不便宜，因为我没有精力和时间去让人自动生成然后清理它们，呃，所以另一种选择是——我知道布莱斯也没有这个精力，并且清理它们。所以另一种选择是，我知道布莱斯也没有这个精力，本也没有，而且他也没有兴趣去做这件事。但所以你必须——我做过一次。我想那是杰森和我做的“所有事物的 constexpr”（constexpr for all the things）演讲。
that Jason and I did. And I think that year there was a push to get transcripts. And Google, YouTube does automatic transcription and just gets it horrendously wrong when it comes to C++ keywords. Constexpr, you know, that's not a word that Google transcription software has heard of, at least not in 2017.
我想那一年大家都在推动获取文字稿。而谷歌的 YouTube 会进行自动转写，但当涉及到 C++ 关键词时，它会错得离谱。constexpr，你知道的，这不是谷歌转写软件听说过的词，至少在 2017 年不是。
So that was an interesting fix-up. And so that's the thing. Bryce and I, we do really care a ton about accessibility. It's just that it is not, it's like they charge by the minute for transcribing that stuff. And, uh, so if there's some company out here that's listening, that's like, Hey, I want to support that. And they want to pay for that to get done. Boom. We're going to have transcripts, but I've already got like 16 things on the go. So it's, it's not that we don't care. It's that, uh, It's prohibitive to do.
所以那是一个有趣的修复过程。这就是情况。布莱斯和我，我们确实非常关心无障碍访问（accessibility）。只是它并不……就像他们对转写这些东西按分钟收费一样。而且，呃，所以如果这里有哪个公司在听，觉得“嘿，我想支持这个”，并且他们想为此付费，轰！我们就会有文字稿了。但我已经有大约 16 件事情在忙了。所以，这不是我们不关心，而是，呃，这样做成本太高了。
Don't have the resources. Yeah. And also, too, like if I had the bandwidth, I definitely would. I just currently don't. But back to my question. At this point, we might be on part two of this podcast. Is that one of the things that really led me to prefer the reduced version or the accumulate version and something we didn't really touch on in the previous uh version is that uh or maybe i'll ask it i'll ask it in the form of a question an interview question i was trying to think of what game show i could do but i don't have the
没有资源。是的。而且，呃，如果我有精力和时间，我绝对会去做的。我目前只是没有。但回到我的问题。此时，我们可能正在进行这个播客的第二部分。真正让我更倾向于 reduce 版本或 accumulate 版本的原因之一，也是我们在上一版中没有真正触及到的，就是——或者也许我会问它，我将以一个问题的形式来问它，一个面试问题。我一直在想我能做什么游戏节目，但我没有精力去想一个游戏节目并把它做成正确的格式。
energy to think of a game show and put it in the right format um sort partial sort nth element all have something in common that transform reduce and reduce and accumulate do not which makes me prefer those well sort at least requires random access iterators is that true the others uh not what i'm thinking of even if it is true it is i believe it is true of all of them that's a bold requirement to place upon so to repeat the repeat the question to the listener partial sort sort and nth element all are in one category reduce accumulate and transform reducer all in another category what's the difference that i'm thinking of there might be multiple yeah i am correct is it the header they're in algorithm versus numeric that actually while i was saying it that popped into my head and i think you're definitely correct
呃……部分排序（partial_sort）、排序（sort）、第 N 个元素（nth_element）都有一些共同点，而 transform_reduce、reduce 和 accumulate 则没有，这让我更喜欢后者。好吧，sort 至少需要随机访问迭代器，是这样吗？其他的，呃，不是我想的那样。即使这是真的，我相信它们所有人都是这样的。这是一个很大胆的要求。所以，重申一下问题——对听众重申一下：partial_sort、sort 和 nth_element 都属于一个类别；reduce、accumulate 和 transform_reduce 都属于另一个类别。我心里想的区别是什么？可能有多个。是的，我是对的。是它们所在的头文件吗？algorithm 与 numeric？其实我刚才说的时候，这个想法就在我脑子里冒出来了，而且我觉得你在这个问题上绝对是对的。
about that um also not what i'm thinking of this is a fundamental property of what the algorithm is something like they're not allowed to oh it's uh uh it's it's in place it modifies correct they're permuting algorithms right and that's actually something that i noticed when i was watching the tyler weaver video is the first thing he does is create a temporary because he's passing in by cons ref and he creates a temporary and just copies it for a lot of them. And for an algorithm where you're just pulling out the top two elements, that's kind of irritating that I'm going to have to permute my input vector or input range, if you will, because this is like one of the really nice things I like about reductions and transform reduces is that they're very functional in the sense that they're not modifying the input range.
呃，也不是我想的那样。这是该算法的一个基本属性。类似于它们不允许——哦，它是，呃，它是就地（in-place）的，它会修改。没错，它们是置换（permuting）算法，对吧？其实这也是我在看泰勒·韦弗（Tyler Weaver）的视频时注意到的一点，他做的第一件事就是创建一个临时变量，因为他是通过常量引用（const ref）传参的，他为它们中的许多算法创建了一个临时变量并只是复制了它。对于一个你只是在提取前两个元素的算法来说，这有点烦人，因为我必须置换我的输入向量（vector）或输入范围（range），如果你愿意的话——因为这是我非常喜欢 reductions 和 transform_reduces 的真正优点之一，它们非常具有函数式风格，因为它们不会修改输入范围。
And a lot of other algorithms, like anytime you reach for nth element, and there's not actually an equivalent nth element copy, which a lot of the times you wouldn't actually want this, at least in this case, you wouldn't want that second, as you always point out, Ben, that is it partition copy is one of the only algorithms that has two output iterators? It's the only algorithm in the standard that has two. And actually, we should talk more about that in a minute because I think it's overlooked. Yeah. And so if you had an nth element copy, which if there's a partition copy, seems like there should be an nth element copy. But there's a lot of those missing sort of prefix suffix algorithms. You could use nth element copy to not modify the input sequence, but then you're going to end up with a range of n minus two elements in, you know, that one of your iterators
还有很多其他的算法，比如任何时候你用到 nth_element 时——实际上并没有一个等效的 nth_element_copy，而很多时候你其实不会想要这个，至少在这种情况下，你不会想要第二个，正如你总是指出的，本，就是 partition_copy 是仅有的几个具有两个输出迭代器的算法之一吗？它是标准库中唯一一个有两个输出迭代器的算法。事实上，我们一会儿应该多谈谈这个，因为我认为它被忽视了。是的。所以如果你有一个 nth_element_copy——如果有 partition_copy 的话，似乎就应该有一个 nth_element_copy。但有很多这种缺失的前缀后缀算法。你可以使用 nth_element_copy 来不修改输入序列，但那样你最终会得到一个包含 n 减 2 个元素的范围……
pointing to that you don't need. And I think that's actually, I can screen share here in a bit if you want to look at the profiling that Tyler did is nth element is actually quite a bit slower than, so like I ended up writing my own, and transform, reduce, and accumulate were definitely the fastest. But nth element was slower than the max element, and then erasing a single value, and then doing another max element. And I think that probably has to do with the fact that you're permuting your input range. Anyways, thoughts? Well, one of the nice things about the non-destructive algorithms, in particular in the parallel case, is you can do multiple different things in parallel on the same dataset. Multiple things in parallel. If you have a read-only dataset, yeah.
指向你不需要的东西。我想这其实——如果你们想看看泰勒做的性能分析，我一会儿可以共享屏幕。nth_element 实际上比……所以我最后自己写了一个，而 transform_reduce 和 accumulate 绝对是最快的。但 nth_element 比 max_element 慢，然后擦除单个值，接着再做一个 max_element 还要慢。我想这可能与你在置换输入范围这一事实有关。无论如何，有什么想法吗？嗯，非破坏性算法的好处之一，特别是在并行情况下，是你可以对同一数据集并行执行多个不同的操作。并行执行多个操作。如果你有一个只读数据集，是的。
That is true, yeah. I guess I don't really think... I always think like sort of data flow pipeline-y, but if you don't think that way and you just use it as sort of like an immutable source, then yeah, you can definitely... I mean, pipelines are just boring graphs, Connor. Just very boring graphs. You just need to think about more interesting graphs. Not when you introduce the phi combinator, Bryce.
确实如此，是的。我想我没有真正去想……我总是像数据流管道那样思考，但如果你不这样想，只是把它当作某种不可变（immutable）的源来使用，那么是的，你绝对可以……我的意思是，管道（pipelines）只是非常无聊的图，康纳。只是非常无聊的图。你只需要考虑更有趣的图。当你引入组合子（phi combinator）时就不是了，布莱斯。
Somebody has just completed their thesis. There was one more thought that as I was listening to your last, to this podcast about the algorithms and Bryce mentioned, I had the thought and Bryce mentioned it that
有人刚刚完成了他们的论文。我还有一个想法，当我听你上一集、听这集关于算法的播客时，布莱斯提到了这一点——我有个想法，布莱斯也提到了——
it's interesting to think about a kind of tricksy way to solve this with min-max element. Is that possible? You had the same and bryce mentioned it that um it's interesting to think about a kind of tricksy way to solve this with min max element is that possible you had the same thought damn man i'm being left out reminded me so i haven't worked through it i don't it is definitely tricky to do because it's it has to be adaptive in the comparator or something yeah um but it reminded me wait does min max element have an overload you can possibly compare it to it yeah really keep talking Ben
思考用 min_max_element 以一种巧妙的方式来解决这个问题是很有趣的。这可能吗？你有同样的想法，布莱斯也提到了这一点——思考用 min_max_element 以一种巧妙的方式来解决这个问题是很有趣的。这可能吗？你也有同样的想法，天哪，老兄，我被冷落了，提醒了我——所以我还没完全理清思路，我不知道——这样做绝对很棘手，因为它的比较器必须是自适应的（adaptive）或者别的什么，是的。但这让我想起——等等，min_max_element 有一个重载版本，你可以把……传进去比较吗？是的。真的，继续说，本。
how would it be useful if you couldn't this is great I love learning stuff live on ADSP have you read the paper A Killer Adversary for Quicksort it's a paper by Doug McElroy he's who is the bashy unix guy he's often cited as the inventor of bash pipelining oh he is one of my heroes then because i love bash
如果不能这样做，它怎么会有用呢？这太棒了，我喜欢在 ADSP 上现场学习新东西。你读过那篇论文吗？《快速排序的杀手级对抗者》（A Killer Adversary for Quicksort）。那是道格·麦克罗伊（Doug McElroy）写的一篇论文，他是那个玩 bash 的 Unix 大牛。他经常被引述为 bash 管道的Přidat发明者。哦，他是我的偶像之一，本，因为我太喜欢 bash 了。
yeah yeah he's he's a great guy um i was lucky enough to attend one of his talks at LambdaConf, I think it was 2015. He talked about... Oh, wow. He presented 12 lines of Haskell that were a complete framework for manipulating polynomials, including infinite sequences. And that was just beautiful. Anyway, highly recommended that that talk uh we'll link it in the show notes so definitely um he has this paper a killer adversary for quicksort which the the the tenet of the paper is um you know we all know that quicksort performs poorly on certain inputs it can go quadratic, right?
对，对，他是个了不起的人。我有幸参加过他在 LambdaConf 上的演讲，我想那是在 2015 年。他谈到了……哦，哇。他展示了 12 行 Haskell 代码，那是一个用于操作多项式的完整框架，包括无限序列。那简直太美妙了。无论如何，强烈推荐那个演讲，我们会在本期节目Shownotes中附上链接，所以绝对要……他有这篇论文《快速排序的杀手级对抗者》，这篇论文的核心信条是……你知道的，我们都知道快速排序在某些输入上表现很差，它可能会变成平方复杂度（quadratic），对吧？
If the pivot selection is poor. And so he constructs a deliberately bad input for Quicksort that is constructed adaptively on the fly to bamboozle Quicksort's pivot selection. Okay. And it's that kind of adaptive nature that, I mean, that's what it made me think of that when I thought about this potential min-max element solution to top two. Because again, it would have to be adaptive in the comparator somehow.
如果枢轴（pivot）选择得很差的话。因此，他为快速排序构建了一个故意很烂的输入，这个输入是在运行过程中自适应地构建的，用来搞砸快速排序的枢轴选择。好吧。正是这种自适应的特性——我的意思是，当我想到这个潜在的用于寻找前两名（top two）的 min_max_element 解决方案时，它让我想到了这一点。因为同样地，它在比较器方面必须在某种程度上是自适应的。
Yeah, and I brought up the min-max element page. It definitely, not that I doubt you, I just had to confirm, because I think I said actually on that episode that min-max element didn't have an overload version that takes a custom comparator, which I apologize to both Bryce and the listener, that is entirely incorrect.
是的，我调出了 min_max_element 的页面。它绝对——倒不是我怀疑你，我只是得确认一下，因为我想我实际上在那集节目里说过，min_max_element 没有接受自定义比较器的重载版本，我要向布莱斯和听众道歉，那完全是错误的。
I will consider accepting your apology but i appreciate that that's a true friendship right there considering accepting yeah well i mean that's actually that's pretty big uh for a big step from bryce he's from he's a he's a new yorker you know uh he's lucky he didn't just right then and there say you you know what, I'm done with this podcast. I am an aggressive megalomaniac, so that is pretty big of me. I appreciate Bryce's self-awareness. It's just that if he wasn't self-aware, I'd just say, this guy is a little bit, but he acknowledges it, so it's all good. It is important to own one's bullshit.
我会考虑接受你的道歉，但我很欣赏这才是真正的纯洁友谊。考虑接受？好吧，我的意思是，这其实挺不容易的，对布莱斯来说是一大步。他是从纽约来的，你知道的，他没当场就说“你知道吗，这个播客我录不下去了”，他已经很幸运了。我是一个有攻击性的自大狂，所以这对我来说已经很了不起额。我很感激布莱斯的自我觉察。只是如果他没有自我觉察，我就会直接说“这家伙有点……”，但他承认了，所以一切都很好。承认自己的胡言乱语是很重要的。
So, yeah, maybe I'm sort of curious. I won't be surprised at this point because we've basically had a blog slash one blog and one YouTube video. So maybe there's a listener that's going to go and create another blog. Can we look at the benchmarks live in large part because I suspect I will find reasons to object to them. Yeah, let's do it. And this will be an instructive episode in how to produce good benchmarks, or at the very least, benchmarks that pass muster with me. Yeah, so maybe this will, I'm not actually sure if this is the start of part three or
所以，是的，也许我有点好奇。我到现在都不会感到惊讶，因为我们基本上已经有了一个博客加一个 YouTube 视频。所以也许会有听众去创建另一个博客。我们可以现场看看基准测试吗？很大程度上是因为我怀疑我会找到反对它们的理由。好吧，我们来吧。这将是关于如何制作好的基准测试，或者至少是能通过我审查的基准测试的有教育意义的一集。是的，所以也许这会——我其实不确定这是第三部分的开始还是
part two, but definitely this is a great, we're talking about profiling now. Let me share my screen. And the listener is actually able to go, we'll link this in the show notes and check out. Oh, man. Actually, you guys are seeing Twitter? At the top of whatever part. We're seeing Audacity. What the heck?
第二部分，但毫无疑问，这是一个很棒的环节，我们现在正在讨论性能分析。让我共享屏幕。听众其实也可以去——我们会在 Shownotes 中附上链接并查看。哦，天哪。事实上，你们看到推特了吗？在任何部分的顶部。我们看到的是 Audacity。搞什么鬼？
Stop sharing. Audacity is the name of the software that we use to record the episodes. Why does it keep on giving you... We're seeing more Audacity. Oh, yeah. That makes sense. Connor, just share your full screen. I've got two monitors. You have nothing to hide from us.
停止共享。Audacity 是我们用来录制节目的软件的名字。为什么它一直给你……我们看到了更多的 Audacity。哦，是的。这就说得通了。康纳，直接共享你的整个屏幕吧。我有两个显示器。你没有什么可对我们隐瞒的。
I am sharing my full screen, but I just can't share both monitors. Wait, that means we've got to look for anything embarrassing in the tabs. No, that's not going to happen. Point free. I mean, I didn't delete it. We'll actually take, before we get to the profiling let's take us we're going to take a small interlude here ben i was going to suggest
我正在共享整个屏幕，但我就是不能同时共享两个显示器。等等，这意味着我们得在标签页里寻找任何尴尬的东西了。不，那不会发生的。无参数。我的意思是，我没有删除它。我们实际上会在进入性能分析之前拿这个……我们要在这里做一个小插曲，本，我本来想建议
also put on the stack the algorithm you talked about from the meetup last night forget it was the uh oh yeah yeah the um yeah what's closest to zero and choose the largest of the two. All right. So we've got three things on the stack at the, what we're going to talk about for a second here is point free.io and a future YouTube video. Cause I got, I got so excited last night and then derailed my meetup for like a good, I said I wasn't going to talk about it for 20 minutes.
把昨晚聚会上你谈到的那个算法也放到栈（stack）上。忘了吧，那是呃——哦，对，对，呃，距离零最近的是哪个，然后在这两个中选择较大的那个。好吧。我们在栈上有三件东西，我们要在这里讨论一会儿的是 pointfree.io 以及未来的 YouTube 视频。因为我——我昨晚太兴奋了，然后把我的聚会搅得偏离了主题足足有——我说我不会谈论它 20 分钟。
And then I proceeded to talk about it for 15 minutes and had to like literally cut myself off because i was i was so excited about it this is what makes the meetup great i mean i felt it i was it was a little too i really sort of i felt like it derailed a little bit too quickly because i'm not sure how many people were following along but i was so i was so excited about it people don't always follow where you're going, but they're excited to be on the journey because of how excited you are. Yeah. So, all right. On the stack, point free is next. Then we're going to look at some profiling from Tyler, and then we're going to talk about an algorithm we discussed last night.
然后我接着谈了 15 分钟，不得不像字面意义上那样打断自己，因为我实在是太兴奋了。这就是让聚会变得伟大的原因——我的意思是，我感觉到了，它有点——我真的觉得它偏离主题有点太快了，因为我不太确定有多少人在跟着听，但我实在是太兴奋了。人们并不总是能跟上你要去的地方，但因为你的热情，他们会很高兴能一起踏上这段旅程。是的。所以，好吧。在栈上，point free 是下一个。然后我们要看一些泰勒做的性能分析，接着我们要讨论昨晚我们讨论的一个算法。
So, I'm confused about your stack because you seem to have inserted it at both ends of the stack. This is true. All right, Q, whatever. It's a stack because we're going to pop off in one direction. That's not what makes a stack. It's a heap. It's a heap. Things have been pushed on by priority and they're going to be popped off in another way.
所以我对你的栈感到困惑，因为你似乎把它插入到了栈的两个端点。确实如此。好吧，队列（Q），随便啦。它是个栈，因为我们要朝一个方向弹出。那不是构成栈的原因。是个堆（heap）。这是个堆。事情是按优先级压入的，然后会以另一种方式弹出。
Exactly. So for context, I have a programming virtual meetup um ben attends from time to time and i think you've been there for most of the uh seven languages in seven weeks and we were covering chapter five and programming language four of seven last night which was scala and one of the problems in the chapter was to write a little tic-tac-toe status function that, given a board that is partially filled out, determine if there's a winner and if it's an X or an O or if there's no winner. And without going into too many details, at one point, there's a function that I used
完全正确。为了提供背景信息，我有一个编程虚拟聚会，本偶尔会参加。我想你参加了大部分关于“七周七种语言”的活动，我们昨晚在讨论第四种编程语言的第五章，也就是 Scala。那一章的问题之一是编写一个小的井字棋（tic-toe）状态函数，给定一个部分填满的棋盘，判断是否有赢家，是 X 赢还是 O 赢，或者没有赢家。在不涉及太多细节的情况下，我在解决 Scala 解决方案和 Haskell 解决方案时使用过一个函数，
in my solution for both a Scala solution and a Haskell solution of a function called all equal to that takes a solution and a Haskell solution of a function called all equal to that takes a character and a string. And it basically just determines is the string, are all the characters in that string equal to the character that you specified? So if you're given all equal to the character x and xxx, it'll return true. And if it's xox or x.x it'll return false and in haskell i had programmed that by basically all equal to uh with a single parameter e for the character and then equals and dot map parentheses equal equal e and parentheses should we be spelling this out for the listener great This is great radio.
一个叫做 all_equal_to 的函数，它接受一个字符和一个字符串。它基本上只是判断这个字符串——该字符串中的所有字符是否都等于你指定的字符？所以如果你给定 all_equal_to 字符 x 和 "xxx"，它会返回 true。如果是 "xox" 或 "x.x"，它会返回 false。在 Haskell 中，我是这样编程的：基本上是 all_equal_to，带有一个表示字符的单个参数 e，然后等于点 map 括号里等于等于 e 括号。我们应该给听众把这个拼出来吗？这真是太棒的广播了。
Yeah, great radio. And you don't really need to follow it or like be spelling it out in your head. But we went to this site, pointfree.io, because I was like, I said just sort of off the cuff during the meetup, you could make this point free, but it probably wouldn't be as readable. Because basically what you're doing
是的，太棒的广播了。你其实不需要跟着它思考，或者在脑子里把它拼出来。但我们访问了这个网站 pointfree.io，因为我当时说——我只是在聚会期间随口说了一句，你可以把这个写成无参数（point free）形式，但它可能没那么可读。因为基本上你正在做的是
is you're mapping a unary function over your string and converting that to a string of booleans that's true if it's equal to your specified character and false if not. And then once you have that list of booleans, you just do a logical and reduction. And if they're all equal to true, you get a true back. If any one of them is equal to false, you get false back. And so that's basically, you could do this with a transform reduce in C++ where you're transforming your characters and your string to Booleans and then doing a logical and reduction. So we plug this into pointfree.io and what we get back, it changes the and, which is our logical and reduction to all, which is is the equivalent of stood all of in C++, and basically takes a list of Booleans.
将一个一元函数映射到你的字符串上，并将其转换为一个布尔值字符串，如果它等于你指定的字符则为 true，否则为 false。一旦你有了这个布尔值列表，你只需做一个逻辑与（and）归约。如果它们全部等于 true，你会得到一个 true。如果有任何一个等于 false，你会得到一个 false。所以这基本上——你可以在 C++ 中用 transform_reduce 来做到这一点，将你的字符和字符串转换为布尔值，然后进行逻辑与归约。所以我们将这个输入到 pointfree.io 中，我们得到的结果是，它将 and（也就是我们的逻辑与归约）改成了 all（这相当于 C++ 中的 std::all_of），并且基本上接受一个布尔值列表。
All takes a list of anything and a unary predicate that's going to evaluate that list of things and turn it into a list of Booleans. And so it turns and into all, keeps the dot, which is the B combinator, the bluebird. Everybody loves the blue bird. And then drops the map and it turns the unary operation into a binary operation. And I'm not even going to really try to begin to explain what happened there. But basically, the B combinator, it's, I mean, do I even attempt, Ben? Do you want to try? It's just, I'll make a YouTube video and maybe
all 接受任何东西的列表和一个一元谓词，该谓词将评估该事物列表并将其转换为布尔值列表。所以它把 and 变成了 all，保留了点（dot，也就是 B 组合子，蓝鸟。每个人都喜欢蓝鸟）。然后去掉了 map，并将一元操作变成了二元操作。我甚至不打算尝试去解释那里发生了什么。但基本上，B 组合子，我的意思是——我甚至要尝试吗，本？你想试试吗？这只是——我会做一个 YouTube 视频，也许
people will understand but I was so excited Jean-Michel who's an attendee he pointed out I was like oh I think I understand what's going on I didn't even notice at first that the and changed to an all this website is pure magic uh Ben do you have anything to add uh I would just say for listen the point of the website is it's called point three because it it changes functions to the point of the function is the argument of the function or the parameter to the function right and so it removes function parameters in favor of plain function composition hence point three so and instead like the c++ analogy instead of having a you know sequence of calls to algorithms where the inputs are explicitly named, having a pipeline of range adapters that can be applied to any input
人们会懂的，但我太兴奋了。让-米歇尔（Jean-Michel），一位参会者指出——我说：“哦，我想我明白是怎么回事了。”我一开始甚至没有注意到 and 变成了 all。这个网站简直是纯粹的魔法，呃，本，你有什么要补充的吗？我只想说，对于听众来说，这个网站的重点在于，它之所以叫 point free，是因为它将函数转换成——函数的重点是函数的参数或指向函数的参数，对吧？因此，它去掉了函数参数，转而采用纯粹的函数组合，因此叫无参数（point_free）。所以，类似于 C++ 的类比，不是有一系列对算法的调用（其中输入被显式命名），而是拥有一个可以应用于任何输入的范围适配器管道，
where the input sequence is an implicit impasse between all of them. Or the other analogy is like, you know, a bash pipeline, where you don't explicitly name, you know, stood in, it's just implicitly passed from thing to thing. Yeah, Eric Niebler was the first one that point because I think at some point, I remarked in a meeting or in a conversation, he was a part of that I said, Oh, C++ doesn't have support for point free. And he said, Oh said that's not actually true if you are building up a custom range adapter that is the composition of you know a transform and a filter and something else um that's technically point free because you never mention your arguments um which i was like oh yeah that's a good point um or at the
其中输入序列是所有这些适配器之间隐式传递的。或者另一个类比是，你知道的，一个 bash 管道，你不会显式命名标准输入（std::in），它只是隐式地从一个东西传到另一个东西。是的，埃里克·尼布勒（Eric Niebler）是第一个指出这一点的人，因为我想在某个时候，我在一次会议或对话中评论过，他是其中的一部分，我说：“哦，C++ 不支持无参数（point free）。”他说：“哦，那其实不是真的，如果你正在构建一个自定义的范围适配器，它是 transform、filter 和其他东西的组合，这在技术上就是无参数的，因为你从不提及你的参数。”当时我想：“哦，是的，这倒是个好观点，”或者至少，
very least you you never mention your primary argument in a lot of cases there you might have an argument of a functor or some other parameter to one of those functions but but not the actual input sequence yeah not not the argument that will be required for basically the the callable that is returned um yeah and yeah and maybe well we're probably not going to have time to to get into all these things but yeah i've been thinking a lot about higher order functions these days. Well, I was going to say, you made the observation here, Conor. So the dot operator is the bluebird combinator, right?
在很多情况下，你从不提及你的主参数。在其中一个函数中，你可能有一个函子（functor）的参数或其他参数，但不是实际的输入序列。是的，不是基本上为返回的可调用对象所需的参数。是的，是的，也许——我们可能没有时间深入探讨所有这些事情，但是的，我最近一直在思考高阶函数。嗯，我想说，康纳，你在这里观察到了。所以点运算符是蓝鸟组合子，对吧？
Function composition. Yep. And you come at this code very much in a combinator mindset, where, at least you said last night, you think about combinators. And the way you think about combinators and the way you think about combinators, you know, you can tell me I'm wrong, but you think of them as functions of one argument. Well, in particular, I guess the Bluebird Combinator
函数组合。是的。你带着非常浓厚的组合子思维来看待这段代码，至少你昨晚说过，你在思考组合子。你思考组合子的方式，你可以告诉我我错了，但你认为它们是一个参数的函数。嗯，特别是，我猜蓝鸟组合子
combines together two functions of one argument, right? And looking at this Haskell 0.3 version is not obvious from that mindset because, of course, the equality operator is a binary operator. It's not a function of one argument. It's a function of two arguments. And indeed, all is a function of two arguments as well. And so at first glance, in that mindset,
将两个一元函数组合在一起，对吧？从这种思维模式来看，看这个 Haskell 的无参数（0.3，应为 point free）版本并不直观，因为当然，相等运算符是一个二元运算符。它不是一个参数的函数。它是两个参数的函数。而且确实，all 也是一个两个参数的函数。所以乍一看，在这种思维模式下，
it looks like how is dot working to combine these two functions because they're not functions of one argument? Except, of course, that in Haskellkell every function is a function of one argument which can then return a function as opposed to returning the eventual results because of partial application being built into the language yep that's and that's that's like a very even to this day i have to like when i start thinking about this stuff like I have to sit down and start. I think like at some point I'm going to have to go and implement a mini, it doesn't have to be Haskell, but basically a language that has currying built in because it is, it's a very different model. Like you said, right in this code, all dot, you know, paren, equal, equal paren. That's the B combinator, which composes two unary functions sitting between. So
看起来点运算符是如何设法组合这两个函数的，因为它们不是一元函数？除非，当然，在 Haskell 中，每个函数都是一个一元函数，然后可以返回一个函数，而不是返回最终结果，因为柯里化（currying）是内建在语言中的。是的，这就是——这甚至直到今天，当我开始思考这些东西时，我都得坐下来开始思考。我想在某个时候我将不得不去实现一个迷你的——它不一定是 Haskell，但基本上是一种内置柯里化的语言，因为它——这是一个非常不同的模型。就像你说的，就在这段代码中，all 顺便（dot），你知道的，括号，等于等于，括号。那是 B 组合子，它介于两个一元函数之间。所以
it's an infix operator. It sits between two binary functions. So two functions that take two arguments. Right. And somehow it works. And somehow it works. It's very, even like the Blackbird, the B1 combinator, one of my favorite combinators. We talked about it in a previous episode where that combines a unary function and a binary function there's a definition of that where basically three beat combinators in a row three bluebirds in a row equals the blackbird and like i have no idea like i have not sit down to like work through the eta reduction or whatever you whatever technique you use but like i've seen that in a talk and a couple other blogs and like i'm just'm just like, I don't even like BBB. I do not understand how that equals B1.
它是一个中缀运算符。它介于两个二元函数之间。所以是两个接受两个参数的函数。而且它不知怎么就起作用了。而且它不知怎么就起作用了。这非常——甚至像黑鸟，B1 组合子，我最喜欢的组合子之一。我们在之前的一期节目中谈到过，它结合了一个一元函数和一个二元函数。有一种定义是，基本上连续三个 B 组合子（三个蓝鸟）等于黑鸟。我简直一无所知——我没有坐下来去推导 eta 归约（eta reduction）或无论你使用什么技巧，但我曾在一次演讲和另外几个博客中看到过，我当时就想：“我甚至不喜欢 BBB。我不明白这怎么就等于 B1。”
But like, that's the whole, I mean, Haskell Curry's very first paper on the topic in 1929 was entitled An Analysis of Logical Substitution. And before he had named it combinatory logic, like that's how he approached it. Like programming languages weren't even a thing back then pre, you know, 30s or 40s. And it was, it was substituting it was substituting one expression for another expression based on these sort of relationships. And yeah, you are definitely correct that I come at it from a very specific mindset.
但这就是全部——我的意思是，哈斯凯尔·柯里（Haskell Curry）在 1929 年关于这个主题的第一篇论文题为《逻辑替换的分析》。在他给组合子逻辑命名之前，这就是他接近它的方式。当时编程语言甚至还不存在，那是 30 年代或 40 年代之前。它是——它是在这些关系的基础上，用一个表达式替换另一个表达式。是的，你说得绝对没错，我是从一种非常特定的思维方式切入的。
That's primarily of how they're used in APL. And then I've been sort of reverse engineering my way into these other sets or know or contexts of haskell and i came to haskell first before combinators so i think about this just in terms of how the types unify and check pretty much interesting and it's interesting because technically i i landed at haskell first but didn't really appreciate what the dot did or really what the dollar sign did. I just sort of knew that if I stuck them in different places, then it would work. And so, yeah, even though I saw them first in Haskell, I didn't really appreciate what they were until coming back from Array Languages.
这主要关于它们在 APL 中的使用方式。然后我一直在逆向工程，进入 Haskell 的这些其他集合或上下文。我先接触了 Haskell，然后才接触组合子，所以我主要根据类型如何统一和检查来思考这个问题，很有趣。而且很有趣，因为严格来说，我首先接触到的是 Haskell，但并没有真正领会点（dot）的作用，也没有真正领会美元符号（$）的作用。我只知道如果把它们放在不同的地方，它就能工作。所以，是的，尽管我最早在 Haskell 中看到了它们，但在从数组语言（Array Languages）回归之前，我并没有真正理解它们是什么。
Well, it's spring. It's a good time to study combinators. I would say I currently have two combinators living outside my front door. I have two finches made a nest in my wreath. And for the last month, I have not been using my front door as a result. They laid, she laid five eggs, of which four hatched. And there are currently at least two baby birds that are still surviving oh you know it's it's sad that some die but that's nature for you that's why that's why she had that number i suppose but yes they're they're surviving and thriving as far as i can tell and the for the
好吧，春天到了。这是研究组合子的好时节。我想说，我目前有两只组合子住在我的前门外。我有两只雀鸟在我的花环里筑巢。在过去的一个月里，因此我一直没有使用我的前门。它们下了——她下了五枚蛋，其中四枚孵化了。目前至少有两只小鸟还在幸存。哦，你知道的，有些死去了令人难过，但这就是自然规律。这就是为什么——这就是为什么她下了那么多蛋，我猜。但是的，据我所能看出的，它们正在幸存并茁壮成长。而且
f combinator is definitely a combinator. Ben, we're going to need some pictures. Yeah. To add to our show notes. I do have a picture. We don't disturb them very much, but I do have one picture. I assume that you had some pictures. And for the listener that hasn't heard the lore of raymond smullion's
f 组合子绝对是一个组合子。本，我们需要一些照片。是的。添加到我们的 Shownotes 中。我确实有一张照片。我们没有过多打扰它们，但我确实有一张照片。我以为你会有一些照片。对于还没听过雷蒙德·斯穆里安（Raymond Smullyan）
tamaka mockingbird and why so a mathematician famous mathematician that um i think i probably heard about it from you ben um or maybe if i first heard about the book from that point free or die talk that was given by amar shah back in like strange loop 2016. But then you mentioned Raymond Smolian and had told me that he was a very well-known and prolific writer of sort of logic puzzle books and math puzzle books. And he wrote this book in 1985 called Tamaka Mockingbird, where he nicknamed all the combinators. And the reason he gave them bird nicknames is because very famously or not so famously, because I only learned this from reading, um, Tamaka Mockingbird is that Haskell Curry, who was, you know, basically did all of the research that led to the, the field of combinatory logic. He was a huge avid birdwatcher and that's why it was
的传说——《嘲笑鸟》（To Mockingbird）以及为什么——有一位著名的数学家——我想我可能是从你那里听说的，本，或者也许我第一次听到这本书是在阿马尔·沙（Amar Shah）大约在 2016 年 Strange Loop 大会上发表的那个“Point Free or Die”演讲中。但后来你提到了雷蒙德·斯穆里安，并告诉我他是一位非常知名且多产的逻辑拼图书和数学拼图书作家。他在 1985 年写了一本书叫《嘲笑鸟》，他在书中给所有的组合子都起了鸟类的绰号。他给它们起鸟类绰号的原因是，非常著名或不是那么著名——因为我是从阅读《嘲笑鸟》中才了解到的——哈斯凯尔·柯里（Haskell Curry），你知道的，他基本上做了所有促成组合子逻辑领域的研究，他是一个狂热的观鸟爱好者，这就是为什么这
basically an homage to him. And, and the funny thing is, is I was at lunch the other day and I'm pretty sure I saw a warbler because i actually through like investigating combinators and spending so much time researching them and tweeting out photos i actually am starting to recognize types of birds and i like i fell off my chair and like ran outside the restaurant to try and get a photo of this warbler because i was like a warbler in the wild that's the w combinators one of the best connor's gonna become a bird watcher connor's gonna become like a bird man he's gonna have like a collection of birds that he cares for this week what may be useful i just heard about this app that's out of um cornell merlin mer? Merlin bird ID? Yeah.
基本上是对他的致敬。有趣的是，我前几天吃午饭时，我很确定我看到了一只莺（warbler），因为实际上通过研究组合子并花那么多时间研究它们并在推特上发照片，我实际上开始认出各种鸟类了。我当时差点从椅子上摔下来，跑出餐馆去试图给这只莺拍张照片，因为我想：“哇，野外的莺！那是 W 组合子，最棒的组合子之一。”康纳要变成一个观鸟者了。康纳要变成一个“鸟人”了。他这周会收藏一类他悉心照料的鸟。也许有用的是，我刚听说了一款来自康奈尔大学的应用程序叫 Merlin？Merlin Bird ID？
Yeah, it's like you just record some audio and then it tells you what it is. But apparently they're doing amazing things identifying birds. About 10 years ago, my dad, who's a bird watcher, had that idea for an app. And he was like, can this be made? And I'm like, like I'm sure it can be but I'm not the person to make it alright moving on to unless do we have anything we want to say about point free tacit programming before we move on to the profiling because Bryce is
是的。是的，就像你只需要录制一些音频，它就能告诉你这是什么鸟。但显然他们在识别鸟类方面做了惊人的事情。大约 10 年前，我爸爸——他是个观鸟者——就有了开发这样一款应用的构想。他说：“这能做出来吗？”我说：“我觉得肯定可以，但我不是那个能做出来的人。”好吧，言归正传，除非关于无参数（point-free）隐式编程我们还有什么想说的，然后再进入性能分析环节，因为布莱斯——
I'm fading fast it's approaching my bedtime I don't know how you're still alive given that you exercised more than me today. I'm wired. I'm wired. We mean, we're talking about birds, combinators. The crash hasn't happened yet.
我快撑不住了。接近我的睡觉时间了。鉴于你今天锻炼得比我还多，我不知道你怎么还活着。我很亢奋。我很亢奋。我的意思是，我们在谈论鸟类、组合子。崩溃还没发生呢。
It's coming. It's coming. I mean, you also have a way earlier bedtime than me. I typically go to sleep at midnight. No, my bedtime has been disrupted the entire winter. Not entirely because of winter, but because of my very active social life. Bring up the profiling. Make Bryce nice and angry so he stays awake.
它要来了。它要来了。我的意思是，你的睡觉时间也比我早得多。我通常在午夜睡觉。不，我的作息整个冬天都被打乱了。不完全是因为冬天，而是因为我非常活跃的社交生活。把性能分析调出来。把布莱斯弄得生气一点，这样他就能保持清醒了。
There are things wrong here, Bryce. Thanks for listening. We hope you enjoyed and have a great day. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
这里有些地方不对劲，布莱斯。感谢收听，希望你喜欢，祝你有美好的一天。这集节目目前还没有评论。点击转写文本中的任意句子即可发表评论。